yo what is up everybody is prestige man
3g here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel video and today you might
notice that prestige what are all these
guns that I've never seen before and
these are new guns that are going to be
released with the DLC and update coming
out on December 16th where we get the
hollow dome onslaught the ten levels
additionally of to level up all of our
characters and we're going to be adding
some new guns now that picture was
tweeted out by the borderlines Twitter
account and so this is a video just
gonna be just quickly summarizing what
each gun might be like and what just yet
to let you guys know that we have new
guns that we can expect for which is
something that I'm really looking
forward to since new having more
original guns is something that would
greatly benefit this game so I'm hoping
that their original so well I'm going to
read through all the guns and what they
appear to be um just based off of their
appearances and some of them actually
say what they are so yeah so we have the
party line the plunkett the t4s dash are
the crybaby boxy and barragan so I so I
only know what one of these is a
reference to I've heard that other one
I've heard other people talk about
references of other things so I'll let
you know what I think in each done as I
go through so first up we have the party
line it's a to Ted your shotgun and it
looked like you know it's to door
because it says Ted you're on it I might
be saying tell you're around I don't
know but it looks and yeah so it take so
I'm getting a little tongue twisted is a
Ted your shotgun that means it comes
with all the parts of at Edgar shotgun
that we normally have it does have the
same barrel the Hyperion barrel is the
conference call so it does look similar
the conference call however I don't
think we're gonna get us to similar to
the conference call because we already
have the viral marker which is really
similar to the conference call from
Borderlands 2 and it this is the only
gun bear with
a kind of gold outline which I think
signifies it to be a legendary and some
people saying like these might be serif
weapons or these might be uh like these
could be uniques seraphs legendaries I I
would be happy if they're legendary /
uniques like that would make me very
happy i would be completely on board
with that so that's what I'm gonna Hopi
and party line does look like it's going
to be legendary now there's the Plunkett
there's the Jacob sniper I think this is
going to be a I think this is going to
be a unique since there is already the
skull masher which is a Jacob sniper
legendary and you there's nothing saying
they can't have to Jacobs sniper
legendaries but I think that might be a
little much ah no that's my opinion and
we'll see if it is a sniper a legendary
or unique or maybe sir i'ma then there's
the t4s are which is a Hyperion pistol
people are saying is it's going to be
electricity based which I am inclined to
agree to think t4s dash or might be
something to do with electricity I'd no
idea what it means but other people said
it might mean something so go that
suicide it's a shock pistol um yeah that
could be Hyperion I it could definitely
be that there is the Logan's gun which I
believe is the Hyperion's legendary
however that that is an old one that
just brought back to this game is I'm
new gun so that'd be cool if that was
that next we have a crybaby which is a
scav assault rifle now this is where
it's interesting the crybaby and boxy
which is a titty or SMG so we have uh
they're both so cry baby is just cry
baby baby oh Christ and boxy was a
person on YouTube who make videos and
talks really fast and someone described
as annoying so a lot of people think
that the boxy is a comparable to the
bein in Borderlands 2 where you shoot it
and it just shouts at you when it's
really annoying however the crybaby has
similar characteristics in the sentence
of that we can expect in the sense of
it's a crybaby so I don't know either of
those or maybe both that'd be kind of
weird might be like the bane from Berlin
see they might shout at you and I think
that'd be kind of funny I be it'd be
funny if they got some boxy audio files
in the YouTube video and they videos and
they played that and lastly we have the
Bergen which is a flat off rocket
launcher and some people said there's a
guy named barragan that is a famous
trumpet player or bugle player I might
have been for a military thing and it
has a school on the end of it which is
pretty cool like on the front of the
barrel or school so it's like skulls
yeah that's cool and that is all the
guns so party line I really feel like
it's gonna be a legendary plunkett I
don't think it's gonna be legendary t4
might be crybaby and boxy I think gonna
be unique and barragan could be raw
could be legendary could be unique I
really don't know and also there is no
there's two door there's Jacobs there's
Hyperion there's scab there's led off
but there's no malo on like that I love
seeing mala want but there is no but
yeah so that's about it for this video
guys i hope you hadn't have enjoyed this
little spiel i'll try and put the link
to the twitter in the description into
the twitter post that is that has the
picture of all these guns so you guys
can see for yourself i hope you guys
liked me telling you guys that there are
new guns since that's what this video is
for so hope you guys enjoyed and I'll
see you all later peace out